Assalamu alaykum Dr. Sah Wlaykumalamu
Muhammad Nawas University teacher from
Peshawar Pakistan. Alhamdulillah I have
studied the Quran. I want to study other
religions. What way should I adopt to
study comparative religion? If there are
your lectures in which you have taught
the way. So please share the link. The
brother has said that he has studied the
Quran. He wants to study comparative
religion. So can I guide him? Which
lecture should he refer to? Is there any
talk of mine? Any program where I teach
about comparative religion? There are
many of my talks, my public lectures
which on comparative religion and there
are books written by me. Since you are
from Pakistan,
you can surely in the religions that you
should concentrate more on compared to
religion is Hinduism and Christianity
since these two religion are the
religions which are maximum followed
besides Islam. So if you want to study
on compassion religion Hinduism, my talk
on similarities between Hinduism and
Islam is a very good talk. You can even
refer to my talk on Mhamad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam in the various world
religious scriptures. You can refer to
my talk on Mhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam in Hindu scriptures. There's
also a talk of mine concept of God in
major world religions. Regarding
Hinduism, you can refer to my talk as
well as my book on similarities between
Islam and Christianity. You can refer to
my book on Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in the Bible and the other
lectures and books on concept of God in
major world religion. Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the
various world religious scriptures and
various lectures of mine are there on
compared religion like salah the
programming towards righteousness. These
talks if you hear it is mainly based on
one of the important verses of dawa
where Allah says in the Quran in surah
Iran chapter number three verse number
see people of book
come to common terms as you which is the
first term Allah is that we worship
that we associate partners with him
that we erect not among ourselves lords
and pits other than Allah then if you
turn back
that we are Muslims bowing our will to
Allah subhanaa tala so this is the
master key for dawa Allah says
come to common terms as I send you so
while doing dawa to a non-Muslim it's
very important that if you start with
common terms inshallah you'll be able to
break dice and you'll be successful. So
you can start talking about common terms
and Allah reminds us here in this verse
the most important is Allah
that we worship them but Allah
that we associate no partners with him.
So while you're doing dawa you can start
with things which are common for example
science or maybe literature or whatever
you feel is common between the person
you're speaking and yourself or the
religion who you're talking about and
Islam but your main aim should be you
may convince him to be truthful you may
convince him not to have alcohol you may
convince him not to have poke but if you
do not remove the shik from the life of
your friend or the person you're talking
your dawa is useless. The most important
is you can talk about other things but
the most important is to if you are not
able to remove the shik in his life if
you're not able to instill your dawa is
useless. So in comparative religion the
most important point of comparative
religion is the concept of God in major
world religions. If you are speaking to
a Christian, you should try and prove
from the Bible. First, you have to prove
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him, he
never claimed divinity. And we can prove
from the Bible. And I say that in my
talk and in my book, there is not a
single unequivocal statement in the
complete Bible where Jesus Christ peace
be upon himself says that he's God or he
says worship me. He says I'm God or he
says worship me. And you can hear my
talks. So similarly when you're doing
dawa to a Hindu your first concept
should be that you should remove the
idol worship from the life of the Hindu
prove to him that according to the Vedas
there's one god you should worship him
alone almighty god has got no image so
your first aspect of dawa is concept of
one god that you worship him alone and
no one else so while doing dawa this is
the most important aspect so first you
should master the commonalities is
between the concept of God and Islam and
other religion and try and win him over
to the second most important aspect
while doing dawa which is the pillar of
Islam. First pillar we bear witness that
there's no god but Allah and we bear
witness that prophet Muhammad is the
messenger of Allah. The second aspect of
dawa is to prove to the non-Muslim that
prophet Muhammad is the last and final
messenger of Allah subhanaa tala. You
can start with you know proving him
about science. If you think he's a man
of science, no problem. But your final
goal should be first. Second isah that
prophet Muhammad is the last and final
messenger. As I mentioned earlier, I've
given talks on this topic. Muhammad
peace be upon him in the Bible. Muhammad
peace be upon him in the Hindu
scriptures. Muhammad peace be upon him
in the world religious scriptures. And
then you can go on for a and for salah
and various aspect. But these two are
the most important aspect. And if you're
able to convince the non-Muslim on these
two aspects, he can enter the fold of
Islam. The remaining will follow. As far
as knowing the structure or how should
you be wellvered in compass religion or
how should you do dawa, I would advise
you that you can visit our platform
Alhaya. Al-Haya is the largest Islamic
video on demand platform in the world.
It has the largest number of Islamic
courses in the world. There are more
than 200 Islamic courses on that out of
which many of the courses are by me and
many on comparative religion and there
are thousands of hours of Islamic video
on this platform. This platform is
absolutely free. You can visit it. And
there is a course which is called as
let's become effective di the
international dhawa training program.
It's a long course and if you take this
course you know there's a study guide
there are questions insh that will help
you a lot in the comparative religion
and will help you to become a good d
also. Hope down for the worst.